Quarter backs on me. Okay, take a knee, take a knee.
Alright sure kind of some nervous energy are excited about seven on seven
And I'm not gonna give a big rah-rah speech. You don't need it. [hey]
You guys are ready to deal you guys have studied hard. You've prepared well, and you're really really flippin good, okay?
She's you have a lot of conference today [should] [be] fun
You should just let it rip. I can promise you 12 [through] 18. [I] mean it is
Splitting hairs literally, how close this is
Who's going to the opening, this is where it gets fun!
We hear it. We say it. We believe it, but can we see it? The (it) factor.
And games online you can see [in] a person's eyes. It's noticeable the if they make the players around them better
Be effective welcome to the in [factory]
Was [a] not recruited out of high school. [yeah], I want to be you guys
I want to come to the kent like this and get some exposure
But we just didn't know what to do and I guess it was good enough
And you got to be on the practice field first and leaving last so you're kind of screwed
So you better help your benefit through the beautiful thing about elite [Eleven] is every year brings back these epic camp counselors
I mean it was Aaron Rogers back in the day mark Sanchez even Carson Palmer sharing their story sharing their path some guys
Let's Max max brown [played] [quarterback] [at] Sc. [fleas] guys. I haven't met yet specifically when max was talking I found tate Martel's eyes
I'd the fairytale high school career
And then I got to college
And that wasn't necessarily the case you can tell his mind was getting ready to explode
Make sure you guys are [looking] at schools that you're gonna want to go to school at not just play Ball. [I]
Just wanted to go to a place. I want to play early
[I] want to be the first guy right when I walk it and you know now
I want to I want to go to a school that has tradition. I want to go to school that you know is
Gonna build me as a person as a player and gives me the best opportunity
Regardless if I'm playing as a freshman or from a redshirt senior. I like Davis Webb's speech
I kind of thought that that got hummed me a little bit kind [of] like how he had to work his [way] up
Some guys they don't get their chance don't get their opportunities put their head down be a bad teammate
You know two ways you say the same or you get better. I didn't get the top 11 out of high school
I'm still pissed about that
And I'm dead serious look at my face now. I still think about that every single day when I wake up because max brown did
But I work my [butt] off and I carried [that] chip still today
Football will always be here. We won't
Hear about Deshaun Watson and his mother you know he's not so much of an extrovert. He's you know he's quiet
He's to himself so just hear him open up a little bit was really special [fifty] years old
[you] know single parent mom four kids and my mom caught me in the room and telling me that you know she has tongue cancer
You gotta take care of my younger brother younger sister?
You know work side jobs [or] the football?
And not the school
They [help] you know my mom take care of the bills and so what I had to do is is kind of grow up fast
And the reason I am the person I am today because of that reason that's just an incredible story. You know it's honestly
it's like if you were put in a situation that would you be able to do the same thing know how to
manage adversity when it hits you all the new kids they had a lot of success early on in life and
in digit Spanish here
I think I said [I] think I believe I faced most everything that most people have in their life
And this is a young man
Who had recently lost his father an iMagine being a big shot in high school football all of a Sudden the man in your life?
Somebody you looked up to who wasn't there?
My grandmother called me. She was like your dad's really sick
He had beat zelda for me, and I went over there for the first time it seemed, and I broke down
Because I never seen him like that every time I look at the [satellite]
He always give me a thumbs up and his smile
And I would that would get me going you can tell that this young man is still processing a loss
But processing it in an extremely positive way
I liked the [Shawn] Kaiser Story
Having to just step up and be the guy
I was a backup quarterback to [two] great Heisman trophy candidates. Who were very good guys
And I truly went in [everyday] trying to prepare as if it was my time [to] step in and be Notre Dame's quarterback
So with that. I think that the lessons I can share with you guys from my experiences truly prepares if
You are the person you want to be not the person you are it's impactful because who they are in their current circumstances
[and] who they were just a few years ago, but to me equally important
They're affirming everything we've done with them saying hey and everything you're about to get trust me
You're gonna use it all because this next part of your journey is way different than you think it's Gonna be
Kind of knew who one through eight were they kind of distanced themselves
But we saw to get 9 10 11 12, and there were probably
nine guys Ten guys
competing for those spots
so if you learn a lot through seven on seven it becomes a culmination of all the learning they've gotten that week and
Can they piece it all together?
What is up?
Perfect here, we go. We're rolling
go
Touchdown that's now Great Bro. Come on D
worse than the law
My God hey that happens it happens wish your wipers wipe it off, whoa great ball
Put them in this pressure cooker situation
That's on me. You can really see
Who's ready for it at the next level but you can also accelerate the process with a guy like Miles, Brennan?
Who's Grown tremendously? And is has taken his game to the next level with seeing this great competition at this event?
Yeah
That's [diddy]
get up in
Definitely dated to test your in tison to test it to see if you had it
I wanted to show the people that you know I have it
myself
Good job, okay, right just stand one let one happen right like that one happened like you got off at too quick his wife
Nope got it got it got it stealing
ice throw Jonathan nice throw nice throw
Jonathan Lewis got a huge arm. He's intimidating physically and he's a learner like he just has sponge
He wants to know more he wants to get better. He wants to be refined
Jonathan working that to that that to that unless that's stealing
Steal unless it's absolutely still okay. I'm a really disciplined kid enough. That's what my parents like raised me on
My parents, they're both from Jamaica each year we go back to Jamaica, and you stay [with] my great-grandmother
Jamaica is not like wealthy. They're
really like poor
It's really eye-opening
Like how fortunate we are to live in America?
And so when I'm old I'm gonna go back and try to help him up a little
They take him back to Jamaica to remind him where they came from to remind him [that] things in life aren't given to you things
In life are earned. I think this young man is gonna have Jamaica cheer inform and potentially the rest of the country oh
Cam Newton's 65 to 45
Jonathan Lewis can boo that guy
Right place and his mental side of the game catches up with all his physical ability his discipline and his work ethic
I go
Hey, that's a that's funky
Hopefully, I can keep pushing keep performing on the field and performing in the workouts and really show what I can do
Nice. Good job Hunter
Yeah
Spread right option yep. [I] wanted to come out and for my best and just do the best
I could with you know the situation
I was given the opportunity I was given so hopefully I'll be able to get invitation to girls open and move on
The biggest standouts for to wait and tommy devito [to] guys that absolutely ripped it
They were near-perfect in there seven on sevens, and it wasn't just that they completed every ball and score a bunch of touchdowns
They did it exactly the way they were taught to do it last night
I really studied my playbook a lot just to make sure I got everything down
But the fact that I went out and did it on the field for seven on seven really made it just fun
All the [whole] works paid off now. I mean now
I'm just trying to get the opening next step and actually be in the Elite 11
time time
Tommy was on the outside looking in but I think that little he's always played with that little chip on his shoulder
Vaulted him in four shirt lock lock him in
tako
- it technically had a perfect day in Seven-on-seven
The way he lives his life and the passion [that] he has I feel like all of that comes out in
Every ball that he throws
My expectations when I came to the eleven was to compete with the best
It's just an amazing journey to have come this [far] in only three days
Not too many kids from boy you get this opportunity and platform to perform at such a high level
quarterbacking ice touch
Riff La Sua, it'll give Hawaii kids
Just a realization that if cool can compete with the best of the best at [they'll] [eat] 11. You know why can't I?
Attaboy [too], huh good cool way to go, babe
Good group man. Really good girl. [I]
Am incredibly proud of the screw
We've asked as much of from you guys as we've asked anybody over the course of this journey
We've been on [Elite] 11 you guys have answered the bell this by far is the best group
[of] arms
But but people. I mean I could not believe sending those interviews yesterday
Guys owe me way
from me
At this age I saw Peyton Tom Brady drew [Brees]
But those are some hall of famers
So think about what went into these guys hearts and their minds to get to the status
They're at today all right. You got a long way to go but boy you got a huge jump start
we arrived at the the end of the camp and
Man what a three days brian wants to talk about we've made some changes this year explain
That sure so we all know name of the event league 11 quarterback [competition] started in 1999
We love the name of Lead 11, but just like the big ten conference loves their name
They now have 16 teams and the big 12 now has 10 teams, but they had great tradition
I had great equity in that name like we do in Elite 11, so at the opening
We're gonna have the elite 11 MVP plus the elite 11 quarterbacks, so we'll have 12 in gold
But it's how we figure this up. It's good work
So now ma'am
How'd you feel this morning after your whirlwind three days better than you think right? Yeah?
They will handle [everything] pretty well
Freaka this morning sucker. It'll probably hit me here in a couple hours
Oh, this is hit a wall and passing like all of us trust me
We had combat interviews and the one question we asked everyone was we're starting a program today
You cannot choose yourself which of the 23 quarterbacks which one would you choose a certain program today?
You were by far
The one that the rest of the group [said] so this group thinks very highly of you not just as a player
but as a person -
We feel equally as high about you, so we're here to invite you to the opening and welcome to part of the Elite 11
This competed amazing here when he's been with us, and he [we] [had] [a] great first leg in the state track meet as well
So excited to see him finish up this process
So mom are you oh I'm sorry and [so] [ours]
How'd you feel like you did today, very well very well
Yes, sir, [two] bad throws, but no, it's gonna happen [new] eyes perfect so can you talk us through one of them um?
Will show [gia] we got it. Yeah, so just talk us through. What's the what's the play? Is it Smith? Yeah? Yeah?
Yeah, I just tried forcing it. Maybe I should have waited a window
could have done that [this] will follow up to our combine interview with you you promised that she'd make the [11] and
[you] did
You didn't try but he's I think is on the verge of it because he like all these other kids they've been idolizing the quarterbacks
That have gone before them and miles just like the other quarterbacks
It's true joy and elation when he got word that he's in bleeped alone
You stamped your place in the 11, and you're gonna have a blast [look]
After damn sure good
So we got our [twelve] going to Oregon?
Right [pam]. Yeah, we're gonna announce the twelve they're going to the opening, but then they're still competing to become the MVP
It's good to be the 11, but MVP no matter what that's my goal
With a high school level when in the [league] 11 MVp is the highest you can do so I'd be unreal to do that
Thought between the pro day workout the combine interviews
I knew the kids as well [on] the field as I did off the field better than in any other year
Just appreciate the way they competed. They're all elite, but also you can only take [so] many to the open
you